i was the snowflake consultant on the
movie frozen
they wanted to get all the snowflakes
right and so they asked me you know how
they grow and i was very pleased when
the movie came out they all looked like
real snowflakes none of them were
eight-sided they were all six-sided and
so good job
my name is ken lee brecht and i'm a
professor of physics here at caltech
and i also grow snowflakes
well i got into physics very early i've
been doing that most of my life maybe
about 20 years ago i just got interested
in how crystals grow and that sort of
led me to ice and to snowflakes we still
don't exactly understand why they look
like they do so it's kind of fun to
think about
to make a snowflake in the lab you start
with water and water vapor and you've
got to get everything cold and basically
start a crystal growing and i'll kind of
blow moist air down onto it and it just
absorbs water vapor from the air and
starts to grow and i can do this on a
piece of glass and so just watch it grow
i'm the only one that makes snowflakes
like this in the lab
when you start to look really carefully
at how a snowflake works
you find you don't understand it and
there's a lot going on you dig deeper
there's more and more stuff and it's
it's really very interesting to me
anyway
i love to go out and sort of hunt for
snowflakes because these beautiful works
of art are just falling all over
and you pick a few of them up and
photograph them and the rest of them you
just trample on at the end of the day
i'm trying to understand how atoms and
molecules fit together to form crystals
and by studying snowflakes slowly you
figure things out that are that are
useful
one snowflake at a time